[Música]
revista de prensa en directo América de
France 24 y nos acompaña esta mañana
Marta Moya Marta bienvenida buena mañana
de viernes ya finalizando semana y
finalizando ya El reemplazo que le hizo
a Rosa Pérez mateu que regresa el
próximo lunes martes vamos a abrir
revista de prensa con los medios locales
de China y también internacionales que
este viernes hacen una premia una previa
del 20 congreso del partido comunista
chino donde el presidente espera hacer
reelegido para su tercer mandato Y
empezamos con la prensa china el global
Times este Raúl buenos días feliz
viernes para ti también empezamos con el
global Times un medio muy asociado y muy
alineado con el partido comunista chino
que titula este viernes el camino
ascendente Cómo llevó el partido
comunista a China de la pobreza al shao
kahn el shao kahn es este término que
emplean para definir que una sociedad
está moderadamente prospera en todos los
aspectos tras alcanzar este shao kahn en
21 el nuevo objetivo para 2049 según
refleja el global Times es hacer de
China un país socialista fuerte
democrático culturalmente avanzado y
armonioso así dice el global Times que
se presenta el congreso del partido
comunista y que dice el china
el partido comunista amplía su consulta
sobre el borrador del informe para el
congreso sostiene que por deseo de shein
Bing el comité central del partido
comunista ampliado estas consultas a los
partidos fuera del partido comunista
para crear un bloque amplio que agregue
Unión de Cara a ese frente amplio
robusto y patriótico para desarrollar
este objetivo de 2049 vamos ahora a la
prensa internacional que dice le secos
en Francia titulan en este periódico
lésbico emperador
emperador de una china que se agota dice
que a sus 69 años el presidente y
secretario general del partido comunista
quiere reelegirse para un tercer mandato
que en los últimos 10 años ha acumulado
todo el poder pero que ahora deberá
lidiar con una economía mucho más mucho
más debilitada Este
desacelere que no me sale la palabra
desaceleramiento de la economía China de
estos últimos meses que dice the Garden
en Reino Unido Marta el de Guardian en
una postura mucho más crítica acerca de
este congreso del partido comunista
sostiene disidentes detenidos y
hostigados mientras Beijing se prepara
para el congreso del partido en los
últimos meses especialmente desde
mediados de septiembre activistas y
opositores al gobierno del partido
comunista han sido detenidos y
compuestos en arresto domiciliario
además denuncian un intento de
silenciamiento para que las críticas que
profesan al partido comunista no calen
en la sociedad y pueda generarse un
clima de tensión en estos días previos a
la celebración del congreso del partido
comunista y cerramos este tema Marta con
cartoon movement Así es destacamos una
caricatura Raúl del artista libanés
hassamblebel que titula emperador del
mundo y vemos a jijimping con una capa
con la el mapa físico de china con La
hoz y el martillo comunistas en una mano
con el Joan en la otra y andando por esa
nueva ruta de la seda que es uno de los
objetivos de chillín y este tema lo
vamos a analizar con nuestra primera
invitada del día pero Mientras seguimos
con un más revista de prensa cambiamos
de tema y seguimos con una fotogalería
que publica el medio Público de Estados
Unidos la radio pública de Estados
Unidos de porque ya se conocieron los
ganadores del concurso fotografía había
Silvestre del año 2022 sí Raúl este es
una foto galería muy bonita la verdad es
un concurso que lidera el Museo de
Historia Natural de Londres y que premia
a los y las fotógrafas que retratan los
aspectos más espectaculares de la vida
Silvestre tanto la fauna como en la
flora entre las fotografías galardonadas
este año pues tenemos a un Enjambre de
abejas retratado en el sur de Texas a
los flamencos celestiales en los salares
bolivianos a una casa de osos en una
isla rusa las barbas de las ballenas
retratados en el Golfo de Tailandia un
cara a cara entre un pollito y una araña
retratada en Massachusetts una serpiente
en el momento que se come a un
murciélago en Quintana Roo en México o
el abrazo entre un simio y su cuidador
en República democrática del Congo Y
estos son los aspectos que demuestran
esas fotografías y esos aspectos más
espectaculares y que a quedan
imperceptibles al ojo humano
espectacular esa foto del abrazo súper
como dedora Marta terminamos o con una
curiosa noticia usted te gustan las
montañas rusas me gustan tiene iPhone 14
14 no Entonces no va a tener problema
para montarse una montaña rusa Marta por
qué Porque mira Raúl esto es una noticia
bien curiosa Y es que los iPhone 14 y
las montañas rusas no se llevan muy bien
porque se los confunden con un accidente
de tráfico y reportan llamadas a los
servicios de emergencia no solo pasa en
el iPhone 14 también en los sistemas más
avanzados del Apple watch y a sus ha
pasado en Estados Unidos recientemente
que las personas se montan en la montaña
rusa alcanzan velocidades de más o menos
50 kilómetros por hora y estas estos
sistemas
estos sistemas reportan que ese
movimiento de la montaña rusa es un
accidente de tráfico entonces llaman al
911 les dan una localización geográfica
de donde se ha reportado el Y bueno pues
esto Apple Todavía no se ha pronunciado
sobre si va o no a implementar una
solución a este tema Por lo pronto la
solución para quien se quiera montar en
una montaña rusa y tenga una un iPhone
14 es poner el modo avión claro o que no
lo montemontañas rusas así también se
evita que se caiga el teléfono por
ejemplo Marta Muchísimas gracias ha sido
un gusto haber compartido contigo estas
mañanas de directo América Pero más
adelante nos vamos a ver no en noviembre
más en noviembre nos vemos Marta un
abrazo Muchísimas gracias